hi I'm Tim for wired and we're here on
the convention floor and we have all of
the movies the TV's the video games all
that stuff but might actually to my
favorite part and the whole convention
is in the small press area that's where
we are now and its people that spend the
last couple months slaving over their
tables and desks and making all this
fantastic stuff all by hand there's
action figures dolls books posters
jewelry pins buttons anything you could
possibly think of my favorite thing that
I saw so far this year is this beastly
this collection it's all these little
creatures that this woman makes by hand
from clay and polymer takes about half
an hour hour to make each one and
they're fantastic they're all unique and
they're they're beautiful these people
are working so hard to get the stuff out
and they're not they're not the big
companies or the little people and
they're at heart they're all makers and
it's it's by far my favorite part of the
show to come and try to see these people
and support all the cool stuff